the eh-2-zed of isms individualism if
someone called you an individualist
would you be flattered or insulted an
individualist might be a rugged John
Wayne a pioneer like Amy Johnson a
creative innovator like Kate Bush an
entrepreneur like Richard Branson people
we admire for refusing to follow the
crowd for being true to themselves but
individualism is also often said to be
the source of Western civilization's
degeneracy accused of leading to
selfishness shallow consumerism the
breakdown of society individualism is a
double-edged sword
many believe its Western roots go right
back to early Christianity Jesus taught
that salvation did not depend on what
tribe you belong to but on how you chose
to live your life God had a one-to-one
relationship with people not two groups
the sixteenth century Protestant
Reformation took this further taking
away the need for priests acts as
intermediaries between God and ordinary
people this sowed the seeds for the
flowering of the modern individual in
the 18th century enlightenment the
prussian philosopher Kant summed up its
key message in the latin phrase sapere
Aude dare to know to think for yourself
personal autonomy became the central
value of Western society we see this in
the principles of one-person one-vote
civil liberties and equal rights for all
but this in many ways welcome
development has gone hand in hand with a
decline of community the growth of
Independence and autonomy leads to a
decline in interdependence and
solidarity in other cultures these
communal values have traditionally taken
precedence across East Asia who you are
cannot be separated from the groups you
belong to that does not mean you lose
your identity in the crown you find your
identity in it as a parent a child a
ruler a teacher an apprentice when we
can all be different and yet all come
together we have harmony the highest
value in Confucian philosophy
across the world individualism is
lamented when it turns us into atomized
units cut off from each other showing
little or no interest in our fellow
citizens but if you can be yourself
while also being part of society
contributing to it your individualism
will be praised and celebrated
[Music]
you